selon une enquête pancanadienne de
l'université dalhousie sur
l'abordabilité des aliments une vaste
majorité de canadiens qui s'inquiètent
de l'augmentation du prix des aliments
et 53 % veulent changer leurs habitudes
en 2020 pour réduire leur facture
d'épicerie en parler avec sylvain
charlebois et le professeur directeur
principal du laboratoire en sciences
analytiques en agroalimentaire à
l'université dalhousie
on le retrouve dans nos studios
d'halifax bonsoir monsieur charlebois
bonsoir alors des pourcentages assez
élevé dans cette étude 87% des gens
disent que les prix des aliments
augmentent plus vite que leurs salaires
ce que ça vous étonne ouais ça l'a
étonné mon équipe on s'attend à des
pourcentages élevés parce qu'évidemment
les gens souvent critique les prix
alimentaires ça ça va de soi mais à 81,7
pour cela ça veut donc dire que la
grande majorité des canadiens
prétendre que le prix des aliments
augmentent plus rapidement que leurs
revenus dans leur capacité de payer la
nourriture qu'ils ont besoin pour
surveiller bien une base donc on
s'appauvrit la face à cette facture est
exactement alors c'est certain que les
choses ont bien changé depuis on 5 le
ménage - canadien dépensé 9 points 6 %
de son budget familial
sur la nourriture ont consacré une bonne
portion maintenant on est au-dessus de
10%
donc on voit vraiment que les choses
changent la par rapport au budget
familial est ce qui est particulier
c'est que ça préoccupe même on le voit
dans l'étude même les gens qui ont des
revenus de 100 mille dollars et plus ça
vous étonne ça ça le hockey en fait
d'abord en bo5 en milieu ni réalité qui
qui est qui et là évidemment les gens
ont toujours des difficultés à se
nourrir et le pourcentage que représente
le budget alimentaire est assez
important par rapport aux ménages qui
vont gagner 80 cents voire 120 mille
dollars par année
mais on le voit dans le sondage que tout
le monde est affecté par par cette
perception old d'abordabilité finalement
on voit le que tout le monde est affecté
par par l'inflation alimentaire qui
dépasse l'inflation générale depuis
maintenant trois ou quatre ans oui
quelques inquiète le plus les canadiens
le monsieur charlebois quelles
catégories d'aliments bas sans surprise
ce sont les catégories où on retrouve
une voix de l'activité de prix assez
prononcé donc les légumes les fruits et
les les viandes
évidemment cette année pour ceux des
légumes les légumes ont augmenté de 15%
en europe et reçoit des gens la
remarquent ils donc c'est pour ça que
ces quatre lots ont été cotées à ces
deux façons élevé bon c'est un sondage
pancanadien est-ce que des différences
qu on note entre les provinces
oui effectivement en fait
personnellement moi j'étais surpris que
il ya deux provinces où la perception du
manque d'abordabilité finalement est
assez élevé c'est l'alberta pour des
raisons qu'on peut comprendre en raison
d'économies mais l'autre province et le
québec le québec est une province où
l'économie quand même on roule bien oui
malgré cela les gens se sentent
vulnérables lorsqu'on lorsqu'ils
visitent leurs supermarchés favoris
alors s'il ya quelque chose de condos de
difficulté à comprendre par rapport au
québec donc si tu vas voir on va donc
prévu et davantage ce qui se passe c'est
peut-être lié avec votre étude du début
décembre où on avait un beau chez plon
10 500 dollars de plus pour une facture
d'épicerie en 2020 sa marque quand même
l'imaginaire et devant ça on on sent
qu'on a des intentions changements
d'habitudes alimentaires en vue là pour
2020 ouais effectivement on se promet un
paquet choses en ces temps ci de l'année
on veut changer le monde
on veut changer notre assiette ou si la
grande majorité des canadiens
veulent moins sortir au restaurant là je
sais pas si c'est quelque chose de réel
parce qu'évidemment tout le monde sort
plus au restaurant d'arrêter tout ça il
faudrait cuisiner davantage
donc je vous pose la question est ce que
vous pensez qu'il ya dix ans vont
cuisiner plus en 2020 ouais c'est des
résolutions du jour de lancement on les
tient pas vraiment puisque je pense que
d'habitude on va recevoir ya beaucoup de
gens qui vont recevoir des livres de
recettes à pour garder que les photos
malheureusement je ne sais pas si ça va
se concrétiser dans la cuisine est bon
mais il ya quand même des changements de
comportement c'est à dire les gens vont
regarder plus du côté des circulaires
les coupons peut-être consomme un peu
bien moins de viande il ya des économies
à faire du côté du surgelé par exemple
vous savez les québécois sont les
champions des circulaires et des coupons
c'est là où on voit c'est au québec où
on a l'intention de tuer davantage des
coupons et circulaires pour 2020
contrairement aux autres provinces et
vous venez de le mentionner le surgelé
le surge aller à une immunité par
rapport à l'inflation alimentaire alors
si vous voyez vos patates augmenté de
20% vos tomates de 15%
allez dans l'allée du sud et sur jolie
vous avez parié sur vous parliez tout à
l'heure le changement de comportement à
l'est moins au restaurant mais si on
regarde les légumes dont les prix
augmentent beaucoup est ce qu'on pourra
s'en priver ce que ça peu précipité de
la malbouffe par exemple c'est certain
c'est un piège
dès que dès que la sécurité alimentaire
d'un peuple est compromis c'est certain
que la qualité de la nutrition vont être
affectés donc c'est pour ça que il ya un
danger actuel mais là on est un peu à la
croisée des chemins et dans tout ça aux
mails dans tout seul les changements
climatiques compliquer les choses
davantage la production la
transformation
alors c'est certain qu'il va falloir se
poser des questions par rapport à bon
comment on on se nourrit et comment on
valorise l'agriculture la transformation
et la distribution pour s'assurer de la
portabilité alimentaire a longtemps
plusieurs préoccupations et des
résolutions ont frôlé prenant prochain
merci beaucoup monsieur charlebois owa
avant